if a society is best judged by the
quality of its mercy while Britain's
socialized medical system appears to be
failing that test 23 months old Alfie
Evans is dying tonight from a
neurological condition doctors have been
unable to diagnose he was taken off life
support by court order on Monday
yesterday an appeals court refused to
let Alfie's parents take him to Italy
which is offering an alternative
treatment and citizenship here to
discuss why little elfies life matters
and what it tells us about socialized
medicine is brexit leader Nigel Farage
in London and this is a live show and
it's the middle of the night Nigel thank
you so much for being here I've been
praying for Alfie and his family but I
have a question for you tonight how can
courts in the EU and in the UK prevent a
family from removing their child from
from a hospital and taking him or her to
another country for treatment how is
that even happening well what's
happening here is the rights of the
parent to do what they think are right
are being taken away from them we have a
case here and by the way it's not the
first we had a big one last year
concerning a small boy called Charlie
guard who wanted to go to America for
treatment treatment that was not
available in the UK and in this case we
young Alfie there's treatment available
in Italy that is not available here now
the little boys very sick but I mean any
parent any parent in the world who's got
a child that sick would move heaven and
earth if somebody else could offer them
a different treatment and yet what
happens here is our state-run medical
system decides there is nothing else
that can be done and backed up by state
courts they make a decision that those
parents are not fit to move their child
somewhere else and when you think about
this case I mean the Pope's intervened
the Italian president even granted the
boy Italian citizenship and still the
medical profession and the courts say no
we're sorry we're putting the plug the
light
support machine has been turned off so
this gets to the absolute heart of how
much freedom does the individual have
how much decision-making process to the
parents have or are our children now
owned by the state I mean Nigel what
it's almost like they broke Alfie's
father today because at the beginning of
the day he was saying come here and see
how my son is a hostage of this hospital
which is what we on the show and so many
others have called him he's like a
hostage of the of the National Health
Service and he said what are we what we
are enduring is not right but by the end
of the day he had changed his tune and
basically said everybody go back to your
lives and I think the hospital kind of
sounds like he was threatened and he
said you're not gonna get anything from
us unless you tone it down there was a
picture yesterday of this hospital all
day hey hospital in Northwest of England
with 20 uniformed police officers
standing outside the door of the
hospital to stop little Alfie being
taken out and to stop protesters from
getting in using the police to keep the
child in the hospital now these parents
have been through every single legal
process available to them and I'm
guessing now that the life-support
machine has been turned off now that
there is no prospect at all of the young
boy going to Italy in the end the father
has accepted the inevitable whether he
was threatened or not I don't know but
what I do know is that when I was
involved in this Charlie guard case last
year I turned up outside the hospital in
this case Great Ormond Street Hospital
in London and I was told in no uncertain
terms by the PR services for the
hospital that what I was doing was
damaging the reputation of the hospital
by doing press reports outside where
this little boy was dying and it is just
it's classic of the establishment
closing ranks the state being
all-powerful and frankly what is
happening today what is happening right
now is a form of state-sponsored
euthanasia and I hate it
he's now an undesirable and we can't
help him maybe undesirable because he
can't be
can't be fixed I think part of it were
almost out of time I think part of it
Nigel is is is is the National Health
Service they don't want to risk the fact
that he goes over to Italy maybe he gets
treatment and he has some quality of
life and that's a big embarrassment to
the National Health Service thank you
for being up late for us Nigel